le fait de d'élever ses enfants
rencontte beaucoup d'admiration la part
des des femmes sans nier votre
personnalité en tant qu'homme quoi s
votre votre existence en tant qu'homme
si j'avais un conseil à leur donner
surtout au matcho c'est d'élever leurs
enfants quoi Henry vous avez 34 ans vous
êtes marié vous êtes père de quatre
enfants 7 ans 5 ans et des jumeaux de 3
ans alors vous vous êtes depuis 3 ans
père au foyer et vous avez abandonné qu
arrêter votre métier d'instituteur pour
vous occuper de vos enfants alors quand
est-ce que vous avez pris cette décision
et pourquoi vous l'avez prise donc on
l'a prise officiellement à l'annonce
donc de de la naissance de nos trois
enfants à partir de ce moment-l on a
commencé à réfléchir à plusieurs
solution et on a pensé que un des deux
parents devait
s'arrêter pour gérer cette famille de
quatre enfants au mieux quoi votre femme
fait quoi ma femme est pharmacienne
et donc on a
pesé tous tous les inconvénients d'un
arrêt de son côté tous les inconvénients
d'un arrêt du mien et puis bon tout ce
qui tout ce qu'on allait pouvoir faire
par rapport à à ce projet quoi mais
c'est vous vous êtes porté volontaire si
je puis dire bah complètement puisque
bon c'est quelque chose que je savais
déjà faire puisque on avait deux deux
enfants auparavant euh que j'avais plus
ou moins élevé aussi puisque j'avais
plus de temps que ma femme puisqu'elle a
un métier donc qui ce qui veut dire que
donc déjà auparavant avant cette
décision vous occupiez davantage les
enfants davantage en temp oui en temp
oui est-ce que vous considérez meilleur
mère que votre femme ah non pas vraiment
enfin je veux dire il y a pas de il y a
pas d'échelle de valeur à à prendre là
entre entre elle et moi quoi je me
considère peut-être meilleur père
que que la majorité des pères puisque
par par par habitude ou par culture les
pères ont tendance à sortir du foyer
pour aller ramener la pétance mais votre
métier d'instituteur c'est un métier que
vous aimiez
oui je pense que de tout ce que j'ai
fait c'était vraiment celui où je me
réaliser le mieux vous l'avez exercé
pendant combien d'années bah de 84 à 90
6 ans
non
mais à un moment il faut faire un choix
entre ce qu'on ce qu'on a décidé dans la
vie affectivement est ce qu'on a décidé
matériellement quoi et
bon c'est bien de s'occuper des enfants
des autres mais c'est bien de s'occuper
des siens aussi quoi et je pouvais pas
faire ça à moitié ni l'un ni l'autre
alors justement c'est quoi une journée
type d'Henry oh ben c'est c'est assez
simple hein on levit donc ça c'est un
moment que auquel on consacre beaucoup
beaucoup de d'attention c'està-dire
qu'on s'arrange pour les
lever longtemps à l'avance qu'on puisse
se prendre un bon petit déjeuner être
être un moment privilégié là de du matin
de façon à ce qu'ils aent pas à l'école
avec avec la tasse dans la main quoi et
là votre femme est là à ce momentl oui
bien sûr bien sûr et ensuite bon ben les
accompagner à l'école donc on les
accompagne tous les deux tous les jours
à l'école quoi ah oui il y a des choses
que vous faites ensemble ah oui on fait
tout ce qu'on peut faire ensemble on le
fait ensemble forcément quoi donc après
je rentre à la maison là je m'occupe de
du repas de midi puisque ma femme rentre
le midi déjeuner bon quand les enfants
n'étaient pas scolarisés je m'occupais
donc des enfants toute la matinée quoi
donc c'était le matin promenade àchat
enfin tout ce ce que les femmes
pratiquent régulièrement et les hommes
qui restent à la maison aussio vous
faites le ménage aussi chez vous ouais
mais on est pas des maniaques du ménage
quoi je veux dire c'est pas on s'attache
pas aux tâches matérielles en priorité
bon vous fait on le fait il y a personne
qui qui viennent vous aider ah non non
non non je veux dire bon ça c'est c'est
mon rôle quoi c'estàd dire que mon rôle
c'est la la nourriture le ménage euh bon
puis tout ce qui est bricolage jardinage
voiture enfin tout ça faut la faut
l'assumer aussi quoi donc ça fait que
bon je suis quand même pas mal occupé
disons que voilà l'intérêt en fait de de
ce changement quoi de du fait que
l'homme reste à la maison c'est qu'une
femme bon je sais pas si c'est par
culture ou par nature j'en sais rien
enfin je pense pas qu'il y a beaucoup de
femmes qui rentrre à la maison qui
mettent les pieds sous la table ou qu'
lire leur journal enfin le le théma ça
se saurait oui ça serait oui et donc
elle elle arrive elle n'a rien à faire
de de contraignant le repas est fait les
enfants pour la plupart du temps manger
ils sont douchés ils sont prêts en
pyjama donc elle tout ce qu'elle a à
faire le soir c'est de les prendre une
bonne heure avec elle le raconter une
histoire les coucher et profiter
pleinement du moment euh du retour du
travail que fait votre femme
pratiquement alors donc elle a 7 he
disponible avec ses enfants mais est-ce
qu'il y a quelque chose qui qui lui est
donné qu'elle fait une tâche qui ben
elle s'occupe du trajet scolaire euh à
la fois donc matériellement c'està dire
avec le véhicule et du du parcours
scolaire des enfants c'estàdire que moi
je je ne supervise rien du tout c'est
elle qui s'occupe de vérifier les
devoirs de de voir les enfants com non
c'est elle qui s'occupe de ça alors vous
êtes ancien instituteur ben j'ai pas
tout faire quoi c'est c'est bien que ça
soit elle qui le fasse parce qu'à ce
moment-là ça marque un intérêt pour ce
que font les enfants dans la journée
puis moi j'ai rien leur prouvé par
rapport à ma présence le soir quoi
puisquil m'ont quotidiennement et puis
prendant toutes les vacances
quoi donc ça fonctionne bien ça
fonctionne très bien ouais très très
bien et vous arrivez simplement sur son
salaire à justement à vous en sortir
financièrement bah c'est c'est difficile
mais on est pas malheureux et je pense
que il y a des gens beaucoup plus
malheureux que nous financièrement quoi
c'està-dire vous vivez en environ avec
une enveloppe de combien par mois ça
fait à peu près bon tout confondu avec
les les prestations auxquelles on a
droit ça doit faire 12000 à à 13000
francs par mois quoi vous vous avez
l'impression que vos enfants sont plus
équilibrés que d'autres
enfants c'est difficile à dire ça ça va
faire hurler quoi
mais enfin pas du fait que je me sois
arrêté moi quoi mais du fait qu'il y a
quelqu'un de disponible pour eux je
pense
que enfin le temps le dira mais je pense
que ils seront plus équilibré bon que
que les enfants qui qui n'ont pas donc
ses repères à la maison
justement vous n'avez pas eu peur vous
que ça ça trouble les repères de de de
vos enfants que ce soit le le le père on
dit papa poule souvent on dit papa poule
oui non mais là je c'est pareil j'ai
rien prouvé non plus de ce côté-là quoi
je veux dire on n pas
euh on n pas fait un choix parce que
j'avais
euh j'avais une féminité excessive ou ma
femme avait une mascité excessive he
c'est pas on n pas unerset euh je veux
dire les enfants savent très bien qui
est le père à la maison et qui est la
mère quoi
donc ce propo là bon papa coq ça serait
plutôt coq c'est quand même il y a la
fierté ouais alors voilà ça c'est
peut-être le côté espagnol qui me reste
c'est la fierté je suis très fier de mes
enfants je suis très fier d'être l'homme
à la maison et de à la fois de de
pouvoir joindre
de deux parties
de de parties de moi-même quoi
c'estàdire être un homme et malgré tout
avoir quand même assez de sensibilité
pour pouvoir gérer l'éducation des
enfants c'estd que là où certains hommes
se sentiraient niés VO vous vous
sentirez de la fierté c'est ce que vous
voulez dire ex exactement parce que
c'est pas facile hein de demander ça à
la majorité des hommes bah je dirais
qu'ils sont bien bêtes parce qu'en
fait le le fait de d'élever ses enfants
rencontte beaucoup d'admiration de la
part des des femmes sans nier votre
personnalité en tant qu'homme quoi s
nier votre votre existence en tant
qu'homme et en fait bon
si j'avais un conseil à le donné surtout
au matcho c'est d'élever leurs enfants
quoi vous voulez dire qu'on est plus
aimé je pense oui mais vous le savez
comment des femmes band dit oui oui dans
dans quelles circonstances
ben le regard des fois quelques mots
échanger dans dans un dans un parc parce
que bon forcément quand je vais dans un
parc avec les enfants je rencontre très
peu d'hommes mais de temps en temps
autour de vous est-ce qu'il vous est
arrivé d'avoir des réactions
négatives donc les gens manquent de
franchise souvent alors il faut que nous
on on décrypte ça quoi mais oui oui bien
sûr
ou quel style oh du style les petites
les petites phrases enfin assez basse
pour pas que on en tienne compte quoi
donc du genre ah toi tu as une queue de
cheval tu es une femme alors venant d'un
enfant quoi de la rue du
quartier donc on essaye d'approfondir un
petit peu la discussion et puis on
s'aperçoit que le petit vous dit oui de
toute façon tu changes les couches donc
on imagine bien que les parents ont dit
quelque chose à la maison mais comme ça
de vioie j'ai jamais rien eu ou alors
des fois des petits clin d'œil
moqueur mais bizarrement le là où je le
vis le plus mal quand il m'arrive de le
vivre mal quoi c'est quand ça vient des
femmes c'est arrivé ça ah oui souvent
quand je circulais avec mes quatre
enfants la poussette double tout le
monde ça faisait un petit peu qu' voit
quoi là c'est vrai que tout le monde se
retournait quoi et souvent on me disait
madame mais je crois que c'est plutôt
par réflexe quoi les gens on vous disait
madame oui bonjour madame les
commerçants oh pardon excusez-moi h ou
alors Monsieur Madame ça vous amusait
voilà moi c'est plutôt j'ai jamais été
vexé à ce moment-là au contraire de
votre femme et de vous quel est celui
qui est le le plus
affectueux démonstrativement moi mais
c'est mon caractère latin
plutôt forcément quoi je je suis très
tactile si on peut dire quoi je je
touche tout le temps quoi alors que ma
femme bon elle sera peut-être aussi
affectueuse que moi mais elle est plus
plus froide d'apparence comme ça donc
vous avez vraiment le rôle de mère et
l'autorité l'interdiction la loi mais
c'est moi aussi
quoi mais c'est tous les deux maisfin
c'est plutôt moi puisquef forcément j'ai
une voix qui porte plus j'ai une
corpulence qui est plus qui est plus
adéquate enfin je veux dire bon ce
schéma il est il est conservé je veux
dire si sil
fonctionne depuis depuis tant d'années
c'est qu' a me quelques raisons quoi je
veux dire faut pas non plus tout tout
dénigrer quoi vous êtes un père
autoritaire oui je pense un peu trop
parfois m c'est vrai ouais on dirait pas
c à dire ben je pense que bon je regarde
un peu ce qui se passe chez les autres
aussi quoi je pense que des fois je suis
un peu trop exigeant par rapport à à tu
Faé vous êtes capable d'en donner je
l'ai fait ouais bien sûr alors qu'est-ce
qui reste à votre femme finalement vous
êtes peut-être au fond un véritable
macho vous AZ peut-être tout ravi toutes
ses fonctions bah il lui reste pas mal
de choses quandme il reste pas mal de
choses bon on donne à nos enfants
l'image que peut-être les les mères
donnent du père c'està-dire que bon nos
enfants savent pertinemment que s'ils
vont en colo c'est grâce à Florence quoi
parce qu'ils savent très bien que c'est
elle qui ramène l'argent à la maison ils
savent très bien que moi j'en gagne pas
quoi comment vos familles respectives
vivent ça la famille de votre femme et
la vôtre par rapport à ma carrière et
par rapport à ma vie de famille j'ai
toujours été surprenant pour ma famille
donc ils sont habitués à avoir des
surprises et du côté de votre
femme peut-être plus peut-être que ça
les a choqué un peu plus par rapport à
au schéma qui s'était
forgé de de la vie de leurs filles
peut-être que je suis pas une réussite à
ce moment-là quoi est-ce que vous n'avez
jamais eu peur que dans sa
tête au cours des 3 années tout à coup
elle est une sorte de mépris est un peu
est un peu fort hein non je pense pas
enfin c'est pas quelque chose qui m'a ça
m'a jamais fur ou perte de d'autorité
perte de et dans le désir amoureux aussi
que ça intervienne non non non ça ça
vous fait rire ouais non là
vraiment aucun aucun malaise quoi je
dire bon le plus dur en fait c'était
d'avoir d'avoir porté ses quatre enfants
pour elle quoi et puis euh de de de se
rétablir en tant que femme bon c'est
bien que vous le disiez pour tous ceux
qui qui seraient tentés qui auraient
peur quoi ouais h là il y a vraiment
qu'un malaise quoi c'est c'est le beau
fix pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
in mire Duma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche